2020 has been a watershed year in digital mental health care. The coronavirus pandemic and a summer of racial reckoning have left many Americans stressed, anxious, and depressed, while at the same time the pandemic has made it more difficult to obtain in-person mental health care. Can technology help to bridge that gap? Many consumers seem to think so. One market research firm found that downloads of the top 20 mental wellness apps rose almost 30% from January to April this year.
2020年是数字心理健康护理的分水岭。新冠疫情和夏天的种族清算让许多美国人感到压力重重、焦虑和抑郁，与此同时，疫情也让人更难获得面对面的心理健康护理。技术能帮助弥合这一差距吗？许多消费者似乎认为可以。一家市场研究公司发现，今年1月至4月期间，前20大心理健康应用程序的下载量增长了近30%。
But among the thousands of apps that aim to help people with everything from stress to anxiety to PTSD to sleep problems, how many are based on solid scientific research, how many live up to what they promise, and how can you as a consumer make informed choices based on your mental health needs? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Stephen Schuller, executive director of One Mind Cyber Guide,
但在旨在帮助人们应对从压力、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）到睡眠问题等各种情况的数千款应用中，有多少是基于坚实的科学研究？有多少能兑现其承诺？作为消费者，你又该如何根据自己的心理健康需求做出明智的选择？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是史蒂芬·舒勒（Stephen Schueller）博士，他是“同一个心智网络导向”（One Mind Cyber Guide）的执行董事，
a nonprofit mental health app reviewing website that's been called the Consumer Reports of Digital Mental Health. He is also a professor in the Department of Social Ecology at the University of California Irvine, where he works on developing and evaluating digital mental health technologies with the goal of expanding access to mental health care. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Schuller. Thanks so much. I'm really excited to be on here.
这是一个非营利性的心理健康应用评测网站，被称为数字心理健康领域的《消费者报告》。他同时也是加州大学尔湾分校（University of California, Irvine）社会生态学系的教授，在那里他致力于开发和评估数字心理健康技术，目标是扩大心理健康服务的获取渠道。欢迎来到“心理学对话”，舒勒博士。非常感谢。我很高兴能来到这里。
As I just mentioned in the intro, One Mind Cyber Guide has been called the Consumer Reports of Digital Mental Health. Why did it get that moniker? What does that mean? And is this something that we need out there in the marketplace? Well, so I definitely think it's something we need out there in the marketplace. There are a host of different digital mental health products, most of these being apps.
正如我刚才在开场白中提到的，“同一个心智网络导向”被称为数字心理健康领域的《消费者报告》。它为什么会有这个绰号？这代表什么意思？这是我们在市场上真正需要的东西吗？嗯，我绝对认为这是我们在市场上需要的东西。现在有各种各样的数字心理健康产品，其中绝大多数都是应用程序。
So if you were to go to the App Store, and to put in the search box, depression, anxiety, stress, PTSD, you would get tens of thousands of responses across those different terms. In fact, some estimates suggest that there's about 20 to 25,000 mental health apps that are out there and trying to find a good one is like finding a needle in a haystack. And so definitely we find that a lot of consumers do need some help in terms of separating the good from the bad, the effective from the not effective, the science backed from the ones that aren't science back. And what we do at One Mind Cyber Guide is we identify and we review products on multiple dimensions.
因此，如果你打开应用商店，在搜索框中输入抑郁、焦虑、压力、PTSD，你会在这些不同的词条下得到数万条结果。事实上，据一些估计，目前大约有2万到2.5万款心理健康应用，要在其中找到一款好的应用就像大海捞针。因此，我们确实发现许多消费者在区分好与坏、有效与无效、有科学依据与没有科学依据方面需要一些帮助。我们在“同一个心智网络导向”所做的工作是，从多个维度识别并评测产品。
We look at how credible is it? Does it have science backing that this product actually works? Is it based off of evidence-based techniques? We look at the user experience. Is it easy to learn, easy to use, easy to navigate? Is it free from technical glitches? And we look at issues around data security and privacy. Does the app live up to standards of regulation?
我们考察其可信度：它是否有科学依据证明该产品确实有效？它是否基于循证技术？我们考察用户体验：它是否易于学习、易于使用、易于导航？是否没有技术故障？我们还考察数据安全和隐私相关的问题：该应用是否符合监管标准？
Does it keep your data safe? Does it not sell your data to third-party individuals? And I think all these things are things that should figure into a decision on whether an app might be a reasonable product for you to try to be able to promote your own mental health and wellness. How do you, at the Cyber Guide, decide which apps to review since there's so many out there covering such a range of conditions? Yeah, it's a good question when we get asked a lot. It's a little bit of an art and a little bit of a science.
它是否能保证你的数据安全？它是否不会将你的数据出售给第三方？我认为所有这些因素都应该纳入决策中，帮助你判断某个应用是否是一款适合你尝试、以促进自身心理健康和福祉的合理产品。既然市面上有那么多应用，涵盖了如此广泛的状况，你们“网络导向”是如何决定评测哪些应用的呢？是的，这是一个很好的问题，也是我们经常被问到的问题。这既有点像门艺术，又有点像门科学。
And so, you know, we really want to focus on products that people are using. So we look at the number of downloads and the use of those products by consumers. We want to focus on products that are backed by science. And so we constantly are looking at the scientific literature in terms of, you know, what works, what is evidence behind it. We also want to focus on things that are useful for people. And so we focus on products that fit the needs of different consumers. We have partnerships with various organizations and they help us figure out what products they're constituents are interested in. And so I think the processes that we use to identify what products
因此，你知道，我们确实希望专注于人们正在使用的产品。所以我们会查看下载量以及消费者对这些产品的实际使用情况。我们希望专注于有科学依据的产品。因此，我们一直在查阅科学文献，看看什么有效，背后有什么证据。我们还希望专注于对人们有用 Dinge。因此，我们专注于符合不同消费者需求的产品。我们与各种组织建立了合作关系，他们帮助我们了解其成员对哪些产品感兴趣。因此，我认为我们用来确定要研究的产品
that we look at kind of aligns with the ways that people decide to use these things, that they hear about them from trusted sources, from their doctors, their friends, from family members, they read articles about them on social media or in websites. Or they might see an advertisement for a product, you know, in a couple different places. And so I think we at One Mind CyberGide, were constantly looking all that information, and then we had prioritized things based off of, again, what people are using and what the science is saying. Who are your reviewers and what are their qualifications? How do they become reviewers for the Cyber Guide?
的过程，与人们决定使用这些东西的方式相吻合：他们从可信的渠道听到关于这些产品的消息，比如他们的医生、朋友、家人，或者在社交媒体或网站上阅读到相关文章。或者他们可能会在好几个不同的地方看到某款产品的广告。因此，我认为我们“同一个心智网络导向”一直在关注所有这些信息，然后根据人们正在使用什么以及科学研究的结论来对产品进行优先排序。你们的评测人员是谁？他们的资质是什么？他们是如何成为“网络导向”的评测人员的？
So One Mind Cyber Guide, we have a team of different reviewers in-house that review different products for our website. And those reviewers all undergo trading to be able to use the materials we used to be able to evaluate products. We also do some contracting out for some of our review material to outside experts, to clinical psychologists and other mental health professionals. But those are usually what we call professional reviews. And so on the One Mind Cyber Guide website, in addition to those criteria that I mentioned, the credibility, the user experience, and transparency around data security and privacy, we also have sort of a narrative. description of how you might use this product in your life?
在“同一个心智网络导向”，我们内部拥有一支由不同评测人员组成的团队，负责为我们的网站评测不同的产品。所有这些评测人员都要接受培训，以便能够使用我们用于评估产品的材料。我们还将部分评测材料外包给外部专家、临床心理学家和其他心理健康专业人士。但这些通常是我们所谓的专业评测。因此，在“同一个心智网络导向”网站上，除了我提到的那些标准——可信度、用户体验以及数据安全和隐私的透明度之外，我们还有一段描述性的文字，
And what are the pros and cons and what are some of the different clinical considerations? And those narrative reviews are all written by professionals. And so the individuals doing those credibility, user experience, and transparency reviews are all members of the One Mind Cyber Guide team that are trained to be able to use those rating scales with fidelity and reliably. Do you collect any information from the users and use that as a basis for how to you review various products? You know, that's a good question.
说明你如何在生活中使用这款产品？它的优缺点是什么？有哪些不同的临床考量？这些叙述性评测全都是由专业人士撰写的。因此，负责可信度、用户体验以及透明度评测的人员，都是“同一个心智网络导向”团队的成员，他们经过培训，能够准确、可靠地使用这些评级量表。你们是否会从用户那里收集任何信息，并将其作为评测各种产品的依据？你知道，这是一个好问题。
I think it's something that would be really useful. It's not something that we actually currently do at One Mind Cyber Guide, but definitely something that we have a lot of interest in. We've done a little bit of that information before, but it's hard to track that. I think that's actually one thing that really necessitates having a product, like One Mind Cyber Guide, is that you would think about where those consumer reviews often live, and those are in the app stores.
我认为这会非常有用。这其实并不是我们目前在“同一个心智网络导向”正在做的事情，但它绝对是我们非常感兴趣的一个方向。我们以前收集过一点这方面的信息，但追踪这些信息很难。我认为，这实际上正是真正需要像“同一个心智网络导向”这样产品的原由之一：你想想那些消费者评测通常出现在哪里，它们都在应用商店里。
And so you go to the app store and you see, you know, this person thinks this is a five-star app, this person thinks this is a four-star app. And what we find is that those ratings and those user ratings from the app stores often don't relate to the credibility and the benefits of those products. Now, I think there's some problems with the way that those ratings appear in the app store. So I think that there's a lot of companies that are probably paying people to put positive ratings in the app store or, you know, they're biased. so only the people are having really good experiences
所以你打开应用商店，你会看到，这个人觉得这是一个五星级的应用，那个人觉得这是一个四星级的应用。但我们发现，应用商店里的这些评分和用户评级，往往与这些产品的可信度和实际益处没有关联。现在，我认为这些评分在应用商店里的呈现方式存在一些问题。所以我想有很多公司可能在花钱让人在应用商店里留下好评，或者，你知道的，它们是有偏差的，
or going to the app stores to leave those ratings. So I don't mean that to say that I don't think consumer, the impact on consumers and the benefits from consumers and the views of consumers are important. I just think it's a tricky thing to figure out how to collect systematically in an unbiased fashion. Like we try to do what the work we do at One Mind Cyber Guide. And it's something that we're still trying to figure out
只有那些有很好体验的人才会去应用商店留下这些评分。所以，我这么说并不是认为消费者的影响、消费者获得的益处以及消费者的看法不重要。我只是觉得，如何以公正的方式系统地收集这些信息是一件很棘手的事情，就像我们在“同一个心智网络导向”努力做的那样。这也是我们仍在摸索的事情，
the best way to be able to incorporate. So I would really hope that that would be something that One Mind Cyber Guide would be using in the future, but I think it's still a really important open question about how to best collect that information. Yeah, kind of risky, like using Yelp to choose the restaurant where you want to eat tonight. Well, and I think that's a great point. And I think, you know, I sort of, I love restaurants, so I like the metaphor. I liked when we used to be able to go to them.
以便找到能够将其纳入其中的最佳方式。所以我真的很希望“同一个心智网络导向”在未来能够使用这一点，但我认为，如何最好地收集这些信息仍然是一个非常重要且有待解决的问题。是的，这有点冒险，就像用Yelp来选择你今晚想去哪家餐馆吃饭一样。嗯，我认为这是一个很好的观点。而且，你知道，我挺喜欢餐馆的，所以我很喜欢这个隐喻。我很怀念我们以前还能去餐馆的时候。
But, you know, I think what we think about sometimes at Cyberguide is that we sort of are the the Michelin Star equivalent. So we have experts going. We're trying to figure out, like, at the best, what is this product capable of? And I think the Yelps are important as well, you know, because there's a lot of information and value that gets added from consumer ratings. And, you know, Michelin Stars and Yelp ratings don't always line up. And I think that we would need both. But I think we need both in a way that sort of acknowledges what are the pros and cons of each approach?
但是，你知道，有时我们在“网络导向”会这样思考：我们有点像是米其林指南的数字版。所以我们有专家去实地考察。我们试图弄清楚，在最佳状态下，这款产品能做到什么程度。而且我认为Yelp也很重要，你知道的，因为消费者评分可以提供大量的信息和价值。而且，你知道，米其林星星和Yelp评分并不总是一致的。我认为我们需要这两者。但我认为我们需要以一种承认每种方法的优缺点的方式将它们结合起来。
If I have a four and a half star rated Taco Bell, I don't think about that as being a lot. on the same standard as a well-reviewed Mexican restaurant that has a Michelin Star, but maybe that tells me something about that particular location. And so I think bringing that information together, I think is really valuable. But again, it has to be done in a way that understands that each of those approaches, the Michelin approach and the Yelper approach, have strengths and limitations. And you want to leverage the strengths while downplaying the limitations. How much should consumers rely on apps for their mental health issues? Are there some conditions that are better suited to apps than others?
如果有一家获得四星半评分的塔可钟（Taco Bell），我不会认为它的标准和一个获得米其林星级的、评论很好的墨西哥餐厅在同一个水平线上，但也许这向我透露了关于那个特定门店的一些信息。因此，我认为将这些信息结合起来真的很有价值。但同样地，必须以一种理解每种方法（米其林方法和Yelp方法）各有利弊的方式来进行。你希望利用各自的优势，同时淡化其局限性。消费者在处理心理健康问题时，该多大程度上依赖应用程序？有些状况是不是比其他状况更适合使用应用程序？
For example, I can't envision someone with a serious mental health issue, such as, say, schizophrenia, getting much help from an app. Yeah, well, first I'd like to say that apps are no replacement for a therapist. These are not meant to be replacements for traditional mental health services or for mental health professionals. And so I think that there's sometimes a false dichotomy made between apps versus traditional treatment. And I think that really the best case scenario should be technology plus traditional services, technology and human services. When we look at the research, however, though, pretty much anything you can treat through a psychosocial intervention through traditional treatments, you can treat using a digital technology. as either in some sort of combination with a human supporter or with some sort of relationship with some human support.
例如，我无法想象一个有严重心理健康问题的人，比如精神分裂症患者，能从应用程序中获得多少帮助。嗯，首先我想说的是，应用程序绝不能替代治疗师。这些并不是为了替代传统的心理健康服务或心理健康专业人员而设计的。因此，我认为有时人们会在应用程序与传统治疗之间做出一种虚假的二分法。我认为最好的情况应该是：技术加传统服务，技术加人类服务。然而，当我们查看研究时，你会发现，基本上你可以通过传统治疗中的心理社会干预来治疗的任何东西，都可以通过数字技术来治疗，
And so there are definitely, there are apps out there for psychosis. There are apps out there for bipolar disorder. There are apps out there for a host of serious mental illnesses. I think actually, you know, interesting, I think one of the products that I'm really interested in when it comes to psychosis and schizophrenia is looking at these cognitive remediation products. So these are technologies that essentially provide brain training to be able to improve the cognitive functioning. And those tools work.
这可以结合某种形式的人工支持，或者与某种人类支持建立某种关系来实现。因此，市面上确实有针对精神病的应用。有针对双相情感障碍的应用。有针对一系列严重精神疾病的应用。其实，你知道，很有意思，我认为在精神病和精神分裂症方面，我真正感兴趣的产品之一是这些认知矫正产品。因此，这些是本质上提供大脑训练以改善认知功能的科技产品。这些工具有效。
There's a lot of robust scientific evidence behind them. But again, those aren't seen as a replacement for some of the other pieces that are part of the treatment than an individual with psychosis or schizophrenia might receive to be able to promote their recovery. So we find that these tools work for a variety of different people. Now, I think depending on the mental health challenge that someone's facing, there might be more or less appropriate uses of these technologies in sort of the continuum of care. So, for example, in the UK, the National Institute for Clinical Excellence actually recommends digital treatments as frontline treatments for the treatment of depression anxiety. They don't have that same recommendation for serious mental illness. And so I think for common mental health issues, these might be very nice sort of frontline treatments or might be ways to sort of really introduce the skills that get taught in traditional psychosocial
它们背后有大量坚实的科学证据支持。但同样地，这些并不被视为患有精神病或精神分裂症的个人在促进康复的过程中可能获得的、属于治疗一部分的其他环节的替代品。因此，我们发现这些工具对各种不同的人都有效。现在，我认为根据个人所面临的心理健康挑战，这些技术在护理连续体中的应用可能会有不同程度的适宜性。例如，在英国，英国国家卫生与临床优化研究所（National Institute for Clinical Excellence）实际上建议将数字疗法作为治疗抑郁和焦虑的一线疗法。他们对严重精神疾病没有提出同样的建议。因此，我认为对于常见的心理健康问题，这些可能是非常不错的一线疗法，或者可以作为真正引入传统心理社会治疗中所教授的技能的方法。
treatments. But for more serious mental illnesses, they might play a slightly different role. So I think research really supports that these things are useful across a variety of conditions, but the way that we use them might differ. How much is this being taught right now in graduate psychology programs? Are people being trained to use apps as part of the therapy that they may offer in the future? I don't think it's a major part of current clinical programs, at least not broadly trained. I think that there's still a developing expertise in this area.
但对于更严重的精神疾病，它们可能会扮演略有不同的角色。因此，我认为研究确实支持这些东西在各种病症中都很有用，但我们使用它们的方式可能会有所不同。目前这门课程在心理学研究生项目中被教授的程度如何？人们是否在接受培训，学会在未来提供的治疗中将应用程序作为一部分来使用？我不认为这是当前临床项目的主要部分，至少没有得到广泛的培训。我认为该领域的专业知识仍在发展中。
I think there's some places where we see a lot of good work in training and implementation. So, for example, the Department of Defense and the Veterans Administration have been frontrunners, both in the development of these tools. They were leading experts in terms of developing some of the first mental health apps, including PTSD coach, and they continue to have a suite of different products. And because they have so many different tools, they're really training people in the DOD and VA to use these tools in their practice. But I think if you go to graduate programs in psychology, there's probably not a lot of work that's really looking at teaching people how to use technology thoughtfully in their clinical work. And so I think this is something that really would be an important area to address in sort of future training programs. And it's something that I care a lot about because I think that, you know, again, this is not technology instead of people.
我认为在某些地方，我们在培训和实施方面看到了很多出色的工作。例如，国防部和退役军人事务部一直是这方面的先驱，无论是在这些工具的开发方面。他们是开发首批心理健康应用（包括PTSD Coach）的领先专家，并且他们继续拥有一系列不同的产品。正因为他们有这么多不同的工具，他们在国防部和退役军人事务部（VA）真正培训人们在实践中使用这些工具。但如果你去看看心理学研究生项目，可能没有太多真正教导人们如何在临床工作中深思熟虑地使用技术的课程。因此，我认为这确实是未来培训项目中需要解决的一个重要领域。这也是我非常关心的问题，因为我认为，再次强调，这是技术不能取代人。
And so I think we need to train a workforce that's educated to use these tools in their practice. What makes for an engaging user experience, why are some apps stickier than others and make users come back? And doesn't that make them more effective if people actually use them, systematically. Yeah, I think that that is the case, that people who use these products more tend to get more out of them.
因此，我认为我们需要培训一支受过教育的劳动力队伍，让他们学会在实践中使用这些工具。是什么造就了引人入胜的用户体验？为什么某些应用比其他应用黏性更高，能让用户不断回访？如果人们确实系统地使用了这些应用，这难道不会让它们更有效吗？是的，我认为确实如此，那些更多使用这些产品的人往往能从中获得更多收益。
I think that the science of engagement is a, it's a challenging area because I think that there are reasons where people may not use a tool as much and still benefit. So for example, there might be,
我认为参与度的科学是一个充满挑战的领域，因为我认为存在这样一种情况：人们可能不会经常使用某个工具，但依然能从中受益。例如，可能会有，
the term I use is happy abandonment, which is, you know, I got what I needed out of this app, and now I don't need to use it anymore. And that there's also some mechanism through which the people who need the most help tend to use the product the most or an app the most. And so there's a relationship between clinical severity and app use that sort of complicates understanding of the relationship between engagements and outcomes.
我称之为“满意地放弃”（happy abandonment）的现象，也就是说，我从这个应用中得到了我需要的东西，现在我不再需要使用它了。而且还存在某种机制，即那些最需要帮助的人往往会最多地使用该产品或应用程序。因此，临床严重程度与应用使用之间存在着一种关系，这使得理解参与度和结果之间的关系变得复杂。
That being said, the only way these things could work is if someone uses it. And so I think to answer your question about what makes these. apps sticky or engaging or makes people want to come back, I think simplicity is a really sort of important piece, that it has to be a product that's easy to use, that integrates into your life well. I think a lot of these sort of digital health technologies make people's lives harder by giving them something more to do and none of us need something more to do in our lives. And so I think the best products are ones that sort of simply and reduce. burden and reduce complication by sort of seamlessly integrating to a person's life.
话虽如此，这些东西要想起作用，前提是得有人使用它。因此，为了回答你关于是什么让这些应用具有黏性、引人入胜或让人想再次回访的问题，我认为简单性是一个非常重要的因素，它必须是一个易于使用、能很好融入你生活的产品。我认为许多此类数字健康技术通过给人们增加更多事情要做，反而让人们的生活变得更艰难，而我们谁也不需要在生活中再增加更多的事情要做。因此，我认为最好的产品是那些通过无缝融入个人的生活，从而简单地减少负担和复杂性的产品。
I think also being able to meet the needs of the user. So some people might really want videos and other forms of media to engage in. Some people might do well from having very brief sort of exercises to read. And so, you know, I think it's also the case that not one app is going to meet the needs of sort of all different users or really appeal to everyone. And so I think understanding who the app is built for and having the content and the interaction styles and the things that really kind of fit that different person. So I think an important implication of that, frame that thinking is that for a consumer, if you're interested in using one of these products, to try a couple different of them.
我认为还要能够满足用户的需求。因此，有些人可能真的很喜欢视频和其他形式的媒体来参与其中。有些人可能通过阅读非常简短的练习就能做得很好。所以，你知道，我也认为不会有一款应用能够满足所有不同用户的需求，或者真正吸引所有人。因此，了解应用是为谁构建的，并拥有真正适合该不同个人的内容、互动风格和各种元素，是非常重要的。我认为这种思维框架的一个重要启示是，对于消费者来说，如果你有兴趣使用这些产品中的一种，可以尝试几种不同的产品。
So if you want to use a mindfulness app to download maybe two or three mindfulness apps, try out a couple of the limitations, see which ones really sort of to fit your lifestyle, the way you like to engage content, the ones that make sense to you, that you like the color schemes, you know, all those things, I think, play a big role. And then to decide to kind of use that product. And I think that's one of the benefits. You know, I kind of introduce this as a challenge is like there's, you know, 20 to 25,000 things out there.
所以，如果你想使用正念应用，不妨下载两到三个正念应用，尝试一些功能限制，看看哪一个真正符合你的生活方式、你喜欢的内容互动方式、对你有意义的、你喜欢其配色方案的应用，你知道，所有这些事情，我认为都发挥着重要作用。然后决定使用那种产品。我认为这也是其中一个好处。你知道，我一开始把这当作一个挑战来介绍，比如有2万到2.5万个应用存在。
So it's really hard to find ones that are evidence-based. But I think the flip side of that is because there's so many, that means if you do a little bit of searching, you might be able to find one that really does fit what you need when you're looking for one of these products. Let's talk a little bit more about data privacy. You mentioned that as being one of the aspects that you look at when you're evaluating apps. And there's been a lot of chatter in the news lately about at least one of these big app companies possibly mining user data for marketing purposes. How much should consumers be worried about this and what can they do to protect themselves? Yeah, I think it's definitely something consumers should be concerned about. And we did a review
所以要找到循证的应用真的很难。但我觉得好的一面是，正因为有这么多应用，这意味着只要你花一点时间搜索，你可能就能找到一个真正符合你需求的产品。让我们多谈谈数据隐私。你提到这是你在评估应用时考察的方面之一。最近新闻中有很多关于至少其中一家大型应用公司可能出于营销目的挖掘用户数据的讨论。消费者应该对此感到多么担忧？他们能做些什么来保护自己？是的，我认为这绝对是消费者应该关注的问题。我们做过一次评测，
where we took a deep dive into the data security privacy policies of about 120 different apps for depression. And we found that about half of those didn't have a data security and
深入研究了大约120款不同抑郁症应用的数据安全隐私政策。我们发现其中大约有一半没有数据安全和隐私政策，
look at is, does the product have a data security and
我们所要考察的是：该产品是否有数据安全和隐私政策？
different in terms of their sense of what data is being collected from them and how comfortable they are with that. So I fully appreciate that when I use Google Maps, Google knows where I'm going all the time. And that's a trade-off I'm willing to make because, you know, I'm not going anywhere that's all that exciting. And I really like to use Google Maps. And so I think that if we think about data and privacy as somewhat transactional, that a person can be, hopefully make an informed decision whether the transaction, the benefit they get from that product is worth whatever they're giving up or potentially giving up when they're using that product. And that's one reason why we actually call our data security and privacy scale, a transparency scale, because to us,
在他们对收集哪些数据以及对此感到多么舒适的看法上，情况各不相同。所以我完全理解，当我使用谷歌地图时，谷歌一直都知道我要去哪里。这是我愿意做出的妥协，因为，你知道，我又不去什么特别刺激的地方，而且我真的很喜欢使用谷歌地图。因此，我认为如果我们把数据和隐私看作某种交易性质的东西，一个人可以、也希望能够做出明智的决定：这笔交易、他们从该产品中获得的益处，是否值得他们放弃或潜在放弃他们在使用该产品时所交出的东西。这也是为什么我们将我们的数据安全和隐私量表称为“透明度量表”的一个原因，因为对我们来说，
it's really the important piece is the transparency of the information, such that a consumer can make an informed decision of whether what information is being collected from them is worth the benefit they're receiving from using that product. So what are some of the best mental health apps out there for various conditions. I mean, I know there's no one-size-fits-all answers, but there must be some that rise above the rest. Yeah, I mean, I think that it's a challenging question. And definitely one thing that we do at One Mind Cyber Guide is we don't endorse any specific product. We have our scores, and we sort of, you know, emphasize, you know, what I've noted for you is that there's different ways to evaluate these things and there's different aspects that
真正重要的部分是信息的透明度，这样消费者就可以做出明智的决定：从使用该产品中获得的益处，是否值得他们被收集这些信息。那么，针对各种不同的状况，市面上最好的一些心理健康应用有哪些？我的意思是，我知道没有放之四海皆准的答案，但也一定有一些应用脱颖而出。是的，我的意思是，这是一个具有挑战性的问题。而且“同一个心智网络导向”绝对不会做的一件事就是背书任何特定的产品。我们有我们的评分，我们只是，你知道的，强调过我向你指出的那些内容，即评估这些东西有不同的方法，而且有不同的方面是
people might care about. So someone might care a lot about credibility. I really want to know that this works and might be kind of technically savvy. And so they're a little bit less concerned about the user experience. On the flip side, maybe someone is more open to a tool that doesn't have as much science behind it if it's really engaging and they like it and it's, you know, really sticky for them. So, you know, I think, again, there's a lot of diversity in terms of what, what fits for, you know, specific people. I mean, I think that as I mentioned, Those VA DOD apps are, you know, they have a lot of evidence behind them. We really like them.
人们可能会关心的。因此，有的人可能非常关心可信度。我真的想知道这管不管用，而且他可能在技术上比较懂行。因此，他们对用户体验的关注可能会少一些。反过来，如果某个工具非常引人入胜、他们很喜欢、而且黏性很高，那么即使它背后的科学依据没那么多，有些人可能也更愿意对这样的工具保持开放态度。所以，你知道，我认为，对于什么才适合特定的人，同样存在着很大的多样性。我的意思是，正如我所提到的，那些来自退伍军人事务部（VA）和国防部（DOD）的应用，你知道的，它们背后有大量的证据支持。我们真的很喜欢它们。
You know, so like PTSD coach. There's a COVID coach app that kind of focuses on stress and anxiety related to COVID. These apps do lean a little bit more towards veterans. And so there's a little bit more of that flavor in some of their content sometimes, which might be a barrier for some people. But I think what's great about those apps is that you know that they're based on evidence-based practices. they have a solid clinical and development team behind them and that you know that they work really well.
你知道，比如PTSD Coach。还有一个COVID Coach应用，主要关注与新冠相关的压力和焦虑。这些应用更倾向于退伍军人。因此，它们的部分内容有时会带有更多这方面的色彩，这可能会成为某些人的使用障碍。但我认为这些应用棒就棒在你知道它们是基于循证实践的，
I think that for a variety of other apps, there are things that maybe kind of align with what you're kind of looking to get. So, for example, our group has been looking at mood tracking apps recently. I really like a mood tracking app called Dalio because it kind of lets me track my moods in a way that's really useful for me, but that might not be useful for everybody. So, you know, I really do sort of encourage, as I noted before, that one of the best ways to kind of find an app that might work for you, you know, go to the One Mind Cyberguide website, poke around a little bit, maybe find two or three apps in an area, you know, two or three meditation apps that seem like the best picks. So maybe you pick headspace, calm, and insight timer. You look at those different products and you see which one kind of fits best for you. And I think that's really an approach that we sort of advocate in terms of trying to figure out. which app a person might end up using to be able to help promote their mental health and wellness.
它们的背后有一个扎实的临床和开发团队，而且你知道它们的效果非常好。我认为对于各种其他应用来说，有一些可能比较符合你想要的东西。例如，我们团队最近一直在研究情绪追踪应用。我真的很喜欢一款名为Daylio的情绪追踪应用，因为它能以一种对我有用、但可能对并非所有人都管用的方式来追踪我的情绪。所以，你知道，我确实鼓励大家——正如我之前所指出的——找到可能适合你的应用的最佳方法之一，就是去“同一个心智网络导向”的网站浏览一下，在某个领域寻找两三个应用，比如挑出两三个看起来是最佳选择的正念应用。所以也许你选择Headspace、Calm和Insight Timer。你看看这些不同的产品，然后看看哪一个最适合你。我认为这确实是我们所倡导的方法，以此来弄清楚
I know the health insurance company that I have at work has given us access to at least one mental health app for free, which you would normally pay for. Is that something that's on the increase where insurance companies are also promoting these apps? Yeah, that's definitely the case. We actually just did a review of that through One Mind Cyber Guide and looked at a couple different insurance companies and found that there were there were a lot of different products that they were providing, although nowhere near as vast as the 25,000 I know that are out there. So probably about like half a dozen or half a dozen to a dozen products that different insurance companies were providing.
一个人最终可能会使用哪个应用来帮助促进他们的心理健康和福祉。我知道我单位购买的健康保险公司已经让我们免费使用至少一款平时需要付费的心理健康应用。这种保险公司也在推广这些应用的情况正在增加吗？是的，绝对是这样。我们最近刚刚通过“同一个心智网络导向”对此进行了一次评测，考察了几家不同的保险公司，发现他们提供了许多不同的产品，尽管远没有市面上那2.5万个那么多。所以，大概有半打到十几款不同保险公司提供的产品。
My insurance company actually provides one as well. So I just got a notification that my strength, which is a cognitive behavioral therapy app, is available through my insurance. And so that is something worth looking at is that if you have insurance and are covered, there might be a product that your insurance is covering that there would usually be a payment associated with it, but you might be able to receive it for free. And then additionally, sometimes these are products that are not publicly available on the app store. So you may not be able to go download it yourself. They usually go through enterprise contracts to companies or insurance companies, insurance providers.
我的保险公司其实也提供了一款。所以我刚刚收到通知，我的Strength（这是一款认知行为疗法应用）可以通过我的保险免费使用。所以这确实是值得关注的一点：如果你有保险并且在保障范围内，可能有一款你的保险正在承保的产品，通常使用它需要付费，但你现在可以免费获得。此外，有时这些产品并不是在应用商店里公开提供的。所以你可能无法自己去下载它们。它们通常是通过企业合同提供给公司或保险公司、保险服务提供商的。
And so you might have some access to some products you might not be able to find on your own through your insurance company. In a recent paper that you published, you wrote about three misconceptions about digital mental health, and one of those misconceptions was that mental health technologies are a new way to deliver psychotherapy. Why is that a misconception if digital mental health is not a new way to deliver therapy? What is it? Yeah, I think that technology offers a lot of opportunities to do things in a new and different way. And so I think that if we are merely translating traditional practices, from therapy to technology,
因此，通过你的保险公司，你可能会获得一些在你自己寻找时可能找不到的产品的访问权限。在你最近发表的一篇论文中，你写到了关于数字心理健康的三个误区，其中一个误区是：心理健康技术是提供心理治疗的新方法。如果数字心理健康不是提供心理治疗的新方法，为什么这是一个误区？那它到底是什么？是的，我认为技术提供了很多以崭新且不同的方式做事的机会。因此，我认为如果我们仅仅是将传统实践从治疗翻译到技术，
we are doing a disservice to individuals who might be able to be better reached and better served by new technology. So for example, let me make sort of a metaphor here is that a lot of these early technologies came out. When they came out, they really had this sort of like session frame of thinking that was present in sort of psychotherapy practice. So it's like you log onto the website,
我们就是在对那些本可以被新技术更好地触达和服务的个人做的不公正的事情。举个例子，我在这里打个比方，很多早期的技术刚问世的时候，它们确实带有一种类似于心理治疗实践中的“疗程框架”的思维模式。所以就像你登录网站，
you do your 50-minute session, You read something for a couple of minutes and you do some exercises. And then you have to wait until next week to get your next session. And that's not the way people use technologies. We're like we're in Netflix. We're an on-demand world. You want things now and you want things in the moment. You know, if I wanted to learn how to cook an omelet and I signed up for a, you know,
进行你50分钟的疗程，阅读几分钟的内容，然后做一些练习。接着你必须等到下周才能进行下一个疗程。而这并不是人们使用技术的方式。我们处于Netflix时代。我们处于一个点播的世界。你现在就要东西，而且要即时得到。你知道，如果我想学做煎蛋卷，然后我去网上注册了一个班，
went to the web and signed up for a class, it would be ridiculous to say that like, okay, well, Stephen, wait a week and we'll teach you out of crack eggs and wait another week and we'll teach you how to cook them. I want a YouTube video that's going to show me on make an omelet right here, and I want to be eating that omelet in 15 minutes. And so I think that technology has the potential to sort of better create these on-demand, real-world experiences. And I think that those lead to some open questions that we have to sort of further evaluate.
去网上注册了一个课程，然后对我说：“好吧，史蒂芬，等一个星期，我们会教你如何打鸡蛋，再等一个星期，我们会教你如何烹饪它们。”这简直太荒谬了。我想要的是一个能教我如何在这里制作煎蛋卷的YouTube视频，而且我希望在15分钟内就能吃到那个煎蛋卷。因此，我认为技术有潜力更好地创造这些点播式的、现实世界的体验。并且我认为这些引出了我们需要进一步评估的一些开放性问题。
I think that, you know, so I think that we need to think about how clinical practices and behavior change techniques, how the science of what we know what works can be translated to technologies. I think we can't merely make a digital version of psychotherapy because that's kind of probably the most boring use of what technology is capable of. Beyond your work with mental health apps, you're also interested in the intersection of technology and mental health. I think that's what we've been talking about. You recently co-authored a report on teens, social media, and mental health that suggested that researchers look at the topic in nuanced ways and not just ask whether social media is good or bad for youth.
我认为，你知道，所以我们需要思考临床实践和行为改变技术如何转化，我们所知道的有效科学如何转化为技术。我认为我们不能仅仅制造心理治疗的数字版本，因为那可能对技术所能实现的功能是最无聊的使用。除了你在心理健康应用方面的工作之外，你还对技术与心理健康的交叉领域感兴趣。我想这正是我们一直在谈论的。你最近合著了一份关于青少年、社交媒体和心理健康的报告，该报告建议研究人员以细致入微的方式看待这个话题，而不是仅仅去问社交媒体对年轻人是好是坏。
Can you talk a little bit more about that report and what you found? Yeah, I think that there is a lot of concern. I think reasonably so right now with as much time as everyone's spending in front of these screens about the impact that screens and social media might be having on people's mental health. And I think sort of more specifically some concerns that the increased rates of social media use are leading to increased rates of things like depression, anxiety, and suicide. I want to just say that I think what we've seen looking across the research is that the research
你能多谈谈那份报告以及你们的发现吗？是的，我认为人们有很多担忧。鉴于每个人花在这些屏幕前的时间如此之长，我认为现在对屏幕和社交媒体可能对人们心理健康产生的影响产生担忧是合乎情理的。并且我认为更具体地说，有一些担忧认为社交媒体使用率的增加导致了抑郁、焦虑和自杀等问题的发生率增加。我想说的是，我们通过查看各项研究发现，这些研究
is not bearing out that relationship. It does not seem that social media use on average or at a whole is leading to the increased rates of these things. I think that there's a lot of nuance there that some people are helped by social media. Some people are hurt. And a lot of people it's probably not doing much of anything when it comes to their mental health and wellness right now. I think one thing that is really important that we talk about that report and I think is important in terms of reframing the debate is that screen time as a concept doesn't have a lot of meaningfulness in the current way we use technology. So like what does an hour of use of Instagram or Twitter look like? You're reading some content. You're creating some content.
并没有支持这种关系。社交媒体的使用平均来看或总体上并没有导致这些问题发生率的增加。我认为这里面有很多细微差别：有些人因为社交媒体而受益，有些人则受到了伤害。而对于许多人来说，它目前对他们的心理健康和福祉并没有起到什么实质性的作用。我认为我们在报告中讨论的一个非常重要的事情，而且对于重新构思这场辩论很重要的是，作为一个概念的“屏幕时间”在我们目前使用技术的方式中并没有太大的意义。比如，使用Instagram或Twitter一个小时是什么样子的？你在阅读一些内容。你在创作一些内容。
you're contributing some content, you're direct messaging with some people. And so I think that one of the sort of things that we sort of note is that to think about screen time in the same way we thought about it with TV shows, radio shows, things where content is much more chunked and something that you absorb is really different in this new world
你在贡献一些内容，你在与某些人进行直接消息沟通。因此，我认为我们指出的事情之一是，不能用我们过去对待电视节目、广播节目那种内容更加成块且被动吸收的方式来看待屏幕时间，在这个新世界里，这种方式真的非常不同，
where you're sort of constantly interacting with these different, these different technologies. And so that we need, you know, better ways to sort of understand what is a person actually doing on these platforms when they are interacting with them. And we need to sort of think more about like what are the wellness facilitating activities and what are the wellness detrimental activities that might take place on these different technology platforms. What do you think the future holds for the use of technology and not just apps for the field of mental health, what do you think would be helpful going forward, both for the field of
在这里，你一直在与这些不同的技术进行互动。因此，我们需要更好的方式来理解一个人在与这些平台互动时究竟在做些什么，我们需要更多地思考在这些不同的技术平台上，有哪些促进健康的活动，又有哪些损害健康的活动。你认为技术（不仅仅是应用）在心理健康领域的未来会怎样？对于心理学领域以及消费者来说，你认为未来怎样做才会有所帮助？是的，我真的认为在未来的10到20年里，我们不会再谈论数字健康或数字心理健康。我们将只谈论健康和心理健康，以及使用技术的方式。我认为技术将深深融入我们看到服务提供和触达人们的方式中。并且我认为当前的疫情确实正在加速这一进程。我们已经看到远程医疗和虚拟访问的使用率真正大幅上升。因此在我看来，下一个阶段确实是在思考我们如何利用技术创造我们刚才谈到过的那种新体验。
psychology and also for consumers? Yeah, I really think that in 10 to 20 years from now, we're not going to be talking about digital health or digital mental health. We're going to talk about health and mental health and ways that uses technology. I think that technology is going to become deeply integrated into the way that we see services delivered and see people reached. And I think that the current pandemic is really accelerating that. I think we've seen a real uptake in the use of telehealth and virtual visits. And I think to me, the next stage is really thinking about how we create those kind of, as we were talking about a little bit earlier, those new sort of experiences using technology.
我认为对于虚拟现实（VR）、增强现实（AR）以及真正让这些东西在人们生活中更加无处不在、更具说服力的不同技术来说，存在着许多令人兴奋的机会。如果许多人想获得心理健康服务或使用工具来促进他们的健康或福祉时，他们迈进的第一扇门实际上首先是一个数字工具，我也不会感到惊讶。我认为这些确实是具有潜在可扩展性、成本效益和有效性的资源，并且我认为我们将在心理健康护理和福祉支持的连续体中看到这些技术得到更多的应用。好吧，非常感谢你今天加入我们。
I think that there's a lot of exciting opportunities for things like virtual reality, augmented reality, different technologies that really make these things much more pervasive and persuasive in people's lives. And it wouldn't surprise me if in a lot of instances that they first door a lot of people walk through when they think about receiving mental health services or using a tool to sort of promote their wellness or well-being is really a digital tool first. I think that these are really potentially scalable, cost-effective, and effective resources, and I think that we'll see a lot more use of these and the sort of continuum of mental health care and wellness support. Well, thank you so much for joining us today,
我认为，虚拟现实、增强现实等技术存在着大量令人兴奋的机会，这些技术确实使这些事物在人们的生活中更加无处不在且具有说服力。而且，如果许多人在考虑接受心理健康服务或使用某种工具来促进他们的健康和福祉时，他们迈出的第一步实际上是一个数字工具，我也不会感到惊讶。我认为这些确实是具有潜在可扩展性、成本效益和有效性的资源，并且我认为我们将在心理健康护理和健康支持的连续统一体中看到这些工具得到更多的应用。非常感谢您今天加入我们，
Dr. Schuller. This has been really interesting, and I hope it's going to be edifying to our listeners. Thanks so much. It was great to be on the program. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne.
舒勒博士。这次访谈非常有趣，希望对我们的听众有所启发。非常感谢。很高兴能参加这个节目。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《心理学说话》的往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。即 Speaking of Psychology，全部连写，在 APA.org。本节目由李·威纳曼制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪恩。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。